Kids love a Disney Princess, and who can blame
them?
They're kind, they're caring, and they're
usually pretty badass, too.
If you're a grown-up, however, you might notice
a whole different side to these iconic movie
characters.
Here are some things only adults notice about
Disney princesses.
It's not all that easy pinning down Beauty
and the Beast's time frame.
The movie falls into that generic post-medieval
era to which so many other fairy tales belong
— you know, the kind of time where the gowns
all have hoop skirts, but where there aren't
so many knights in shining armor around.
However, Luke Evans, who plays Gaston in 2017's
Beauty and the Beast, narrowed the era down
considerably in an interview with Entertainment
Weekly, saying:
"When [Gaston] was about 16, he protected
the town from a pack of Portuguese marauders
in 1740."
Based on this assertion, you can safely assume
that Beauty and the Beast takes place in the
1750s, perhaps as late as 1760.
And sure, the reign of Louis XV serves as
a good backdrop for this beloved romance...
until you remember what happened a couple
of decades later.
Yes, it seems likely that Belle and the Beast
are going to find themselves in a spot of
bother once the French Revolution comes around
in 1789.
Luckily, their grisly fate isn't quite set
in stone.
In 2020, Disney launched The Queen's Council,
a new line of historical novels that intertwine
their heroines' stories with actual historical
events.
And sure enough, Rebel Rose, the first book
in the series, finds Belle living in 1789.
She's just freed the Beast from his spell,
but the Revolution is coming to town — and
she soon finds herself torn between her roots
as a commoner and her future as a royal.
Sounds like she'd better start teaching Lumiere
the words to "La Marseillaise."
Kids will be easily swept up in Pocahontas'
tale of conflict, harmony, and sentient willow
trees.
But adults will likely be aware of just how
much Disney's version differs from the actual
story.
So what are the biggest differences between
real life and the silver screen?
Well, firstly, the woman known as Pocahontas
wasn't actually called Pocahontas.
She was named Amonute, and sometimes also
known as Matoaka.
"Pocahontas" was a nickname meaning "little
wanton," which she garnered for her mischievous
nature.
"Little" is the key word there, of course,
because Pocahontas certainly was little.
In fact, she was roughly 11 or 12 when she
rescued John Smith.
Even the veracity of that rescue is in doubt,
however, as some historians suggest Smith
lifted the tale entirely from a popular ballad.
Pocahontas was later kidnapped by an English
colonist and used as a bargaining chip during
the First Anglo-Powhatan War.
She was eventually taken to another English
settlement, where she converted to Christianity,
took the name Rebecca, and accepted a marriage
proposal from a man named John Rolfe.
Though this marriage led to a truce known
as the "Peace of Pocahontas," the woman herself
died in England only a handful of years after
her marriage, at the age of 21.
Disney isn't the first to co-opt Pocahontas
for their own purposes, and they won't be
the last — but that doesn't change the awful
truth behind her real-life story.
Mulan has got to be one of the most courageous
Disney Princesses of all.
Despite her lack of training, her insecurities,
and the limitations placed on her because
of her gender, Mulan goes to war in her father's
place.
Luckily, everything turns out pretty much
okay — she saves the day, wins the war,
and reunites with her father.
Not every version of Mulan's tale ends so
well, however.
If you're familiar with the ancient folk stories
that inspired Mulan, you'll know that her
story has carried all kinds of moral lessons
over the years, including a few that aren't
exactly family-friendly.
For example, Chu Renhuo, author of the late-17th
century Romance of Sui and Tang, depicts Mulan
as a virtuous warrior — one who becomes
a sworn sister to the benighted Princess Xianniang.
Tragically, the respect she earns while posing
as a man pretty much vanishes when it's revealed
that she's actually a woman.
Rather than be forced into concubinage, Mulan
cuts her own throat over her father's grave.
And this is just one of many versions of Mulan's
story; one that demonstrates just how much
a story can change over the course of history.
The Princess and the Frog is unique among
Disney movies in that it has a very specific,
real-world setting: New Orleans in 1928.
Granted, there are a few liberties taken here
and there, but by and large, Tiana lives in
the world as we know it.
World War I took her father from her, so-called
sugar barons and cotton kings dominate the
Louisiana she lives in, and businessmen dismiss
her ambitions for regrettably predictable
reasons.
"A little woman of your background would have
had her hands full trying to run a big business
like that."
Of course, Tiana ends up proving the naysayers
wrong.
Best of all, even her success is rooted in
history.
Tiana was inspired by Leah Chase, a legendary
chef known as the "Queen of Creole Cuisine."
Her restaurant, Dooky Chase, is an American
landmark, having become a gathering place
for the members of the Civil Rights Movement,
a dazzling art gallery, and of course, a celebrated
beacon of Creole cooking.
Dooky Chase has served leaders and luminaries
ranging from Barack Obama to Ray Charles,
who even mentions the restaurant in "Early
Morning Blues."
Chase, who was delighted to serve as the inspiration
for Tiana, passed away in 2019 at the age
of 96.
Her legacy lives on in her restaurant, her
cooking, and, of course, The Princess and
the Frog.
What is a Disney princess?
Well, that's easy — it's a princess from
a Disney movie, right?
And sure, things can get a little fuzzy…
"Okay, first, I'm not a princess.
I'm the daughter of the chief."
"Same difference."
"No."
"If you wear a dress and you have an animal
sidekick, you’re a princess."
...but the definition generally holds.
Then again, what about Mulan?
As a commoner, albeit one of great distinction,
Mulan isn't a princess, even by the most generous
definition of the word.
Moreover, neither Elsa nor Anna from Frozen
are considered official Disney princesses.
Even if you allow for Elsa's exclusion, given
the fact that she is a Queen, that doesn't
explain why Anna wasn't considered one when
the first movie came out.
In reality, 'what makes a Disney princess?'
is a question with no real answer, and the
literal definition of a princess has never
really mattered much.
As long-time Disney fans might recall, Mulan
has been part of the line from the very beginning,
as was Tinker Bell — until she was removed
to lead the Disney Fairies franchise.
Even Anna and Elsa's position has also grown
murkier in recent years.
Their inclusion in Ralph Breaks the Internet's
princess-centric scenes can be taken as evidence
that they are now considered Disney Princesses,
yet they remain absent from the official Disney
Princess website.
So what gives?
What actually makes a Disney Princess?
For now, the answer remains a mystery.
Believe it or not, some people weren't exactly
keen on the idea of a line of Disney Princesses.
Roy E. Disney, Walt Disney's nephew and a
longtime executive at the company, was among
the most outspoken critics of the franchise.
He believed that bringing the princesses together
under one brand would basically destroy the
value of their movies.
This had been the prevailing wisdom for years,
too.
Once upon a time, an Ariel doll would have
been very clearly marketed as a Little Mermaid,
while a Jasmine doll would have been marketed
as an Aladdin toy.
Disney and those of like minds believed that
the movies were the core of the company, and
shouldn't be messed with under any circumstance.
Obviously, the Disney Princess idea prevailed,
and went on to earn the company billions of
dollars.
But the critics managed to win a few concessions.
For example, each princess is distinguished
by a signature color, meaning that Aurora's
infamously color-changing dress was made to
settle on pink, so as not to compete with
Cinderella.
Strangest of all, however, it was agreed that
the princesses should never make eye contact.
Whether they appeared together on backpacks,
cereal boxes, and posters, they were to give
no indication that they existed on the same
plane as the princess beside them.
These days, however, you've got to assume
that this rule is no longer strictly observed,
given — well, this.
"Do you have daddy issues?"
"I don't even have a mom!"
"Neither do we!"
Picture this: a band of heroes from a range
of Disney movies gather together to fight
evil in one epic blockbuster movie.
Sure, your mind might go to these guys, but
forget about them for a minute.
What about a movie that brings together every
Disney princess?
Of course, an idea like that would have seemed
absurd once, but in the era of the cinematic
universe, all things are possible — as Ralph
Breaks the Internet proved back in 2018.
Though the Disney Princesses take up little
of Ralph's runtime, they made a huge impact
on the discourse surrounding the movie.
Multiple news items dissecting, discussing,
and celebrating the scene sprung up in the
movie's wake, a boatload of merchandise of
the princesses in their loungewear was released,
and fan speculation over a pan-princess movie
began in earnest.
And these aren't just idle fan rumors, either.
Ralph directors Phil Johnston and Rich Moore
have considered the possibility themselves.
In an interview with The A.V.
Club, Moore called it, quote, "an idea worth
exploring," revealing that no matter where
the movie played, "fans [were] off the charts"
about the princess scene.
Though they noted that they have no idea if
this is an idea that Disney is considering,
the fact that it was brought up at all shows
that there's some serious creative interest
about a Disney Princess crossover movie.
The world of Disney Princess merchandise is
vast and ever-expanding.
Even the luckiest kid in the world couldn't
hope to own every single Princess-branded
item pushed out into the marketplace — and
that's only counting the stuff explicitly
meant for kids.
While most Disney Princess merch is indeed
for children, there's a whole range of products
featuring Disney Princesses that's squarely
aimed at grown-ups.
Considering tying the knot?
You can now put a Disney Princess engagement
ring on it, then walk down the aisle in a
Disney Princess wedding dress.
Want to keep the Disney spirit alive as you
eat?
You can buy a 16-piece dinnerware set inspired
by your heroine of choice.
Looking to primp in princess style?
Then drop a few hundred bucks on some Disney
Princess-branded makeup.
You can even liven up boring, grown-up tasks
like meal planning and bill payment with the
official Disney Princess planner.
You can't say they don't go all-out, can you?
Ideally, a trip to a Disney park should feel
effortlessly magical.
And the passion these parks inspire in their
legions of devotees proves that, most of the
time, Disney just about pulls it off.
But when it comes to hanging out with the
princesses themselves, things start feeling
a lot less effortless.
Now, meeting the princesses is certainly possible.
They're placed all over the park, and are
usually available for photos, autographs,
and tearful confessions of childhood love.
But then there are the rarer events, like
Cinderella's Royal Table, a luxurious meal
at Cinderella's Castle that features appearances
from the princesses themselves.
These events are a whole lot harder to attend,
and thousands of posts, articles, and blogs
exist that aim to help park goers wrangle
a reservation.
According to one intrepid mom, Cinderella's
Royal Table requires an aspiring dinner guest
call exactly 180 days prior to the desired
date, at precisely 7 AM.
Not even that is foolproof, however, and some
gurus suggest making multiple reservations,
lest one time become untenable.
This sort of reservation-hoarding is controversial,
to say the least, but when it comes to making
the magic happen for little ones, most parents
are willing to play a little dirty.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.